[Music]
found among the papers of the late
dedrick knickerbocker
a pleasing land of drowsy head it was of
dreams that wave before the half-shut
eye
and of gay castles in the clouds that
pass forever flushing
round a summer sky castle of indolence
in the bosom of one of those spacious
coves which indent
the eastern shore of the hudson at that
broad expansion of the river denominated
by the ancient dutch navigators
as the tappan zee and where they always
prudently shortened sail
and implored the protection of saint
nicholas when they crossed
there lies a small market town or rural
port
which by some is called greensburg but
which is more generally and properly
known by the name of terrytown
this name was given we are told in
former days
by the good housewives of the adjacent
country from the inveterate propensity
of their husbands
to linger about the village tavern on
market days
be that as it may i do not vouch for the
fact but merely advert to it
for the sake of being precise and
authentic
not far from this village perhaps about
two miles
there is a little valley or rather lap
of land among high hills
which is one of the quietest places in
the whole world
a small brook glides through it with
just murmur enough to lull one to repose
and the occasional whistle of a quail or
tapping of a woodpecker
is almost the only sound that ever
breaks in upon the uniform
tranquility i recollect that when is
stripping
my first exploit in squirrel shooting
was in a grove of tall walnut trees that
shades one side of the valley
i had wandered into it at noon time when
all nature is peculiarly quiet
and was startled by the roar of my own
gun as it broke the sabbath stillness
around
and was prolonged and reverberated by
the angry echoes
if ever i should wish for a retreat
whither i might steal from the world and
its distractions
and dream quietly away the remnant of a
troubled life
i know of none more promising than this
little valley
from the listless repose of the place
and the peculiar character of its
inhabitants
who are descendants from the original
dutch settlers
this sequestered glenn has long been
known by the name of sleepy hollow
and its rustic lads are called the
sleepy hollow boys
throughout all of the neighboring
country a drowsy dreamy
influence seems to hang over the land
and to pervade the very atmosphere
some say that the place was bewitched by
a high german doctor
during the early days of the settlement
others
that an old indian chief the prophet or
wizard of his tribe
held his powwows there before the
country was discovered by master hendrik
hudson
certain it is the place still continues
under the sway of some witching power
that holds a spell over the minds of the
good people
causing them to walk in a continual
revery
they are given to all kinds of marvelous
beliefs
are subject to trances and visions and
frequently see
strange sights and hear music and voices
in the air
the whole neighborhood abounds with
local tales haunted spots
and twilight superstitions stars shoot
and meteors glare often are across the
valley
than in any other part of the country
and the nightmare
with her whole ninefold seems to make it
the favorite scene of her gambles
the dominant spirit however that haunts
this enchanted region
and seems to be commander in chief of
all the powers of the
air is the apparition of a figure on
horseback
without a head it is said by some to be
the ghost of a hessian trooper
whose head had been carried away by a
cannonball
in some nameless battle during the
revolutionary war
and who is ever in anon seen by the
country folk
hurrying along in the gloom of night as
if on the wings of the wind
his haunts are not confined to the
valley but extend at times to the
adjacent roads
and especially to the vicinity of a
church at no great distance
indeed certain of the most authentic
historians of those parts
who have been careful in collecting and
collating the floating facts concerning
this spectre
alleged that the body of the trooper
having been buried in the churchyard
the ghost rides forth to the scene of
battle in nightly quest of his head
and that the rushing speed with which he
sometimes passes along the hollow
like a midnight blast is owing to his
being belated
and in a hurry to get back to the
churchyard before daybreak
such is the general purport of this
legendary superstition
which has furnished materials for many a
wild story
in that region of shadows and the
spectre is known
at all the country firesides by the name
of the headless horseman of sleepy
hollow
it is remarkable that the visionary
propensity i have mentioned
is not confined to the native
inhabitants of the valley
but is unconsciously imbibed by everyone
who resides there for a time
however wide awake they may have been
before they entered that sleepy region
they are sure in a little time to inhale
the witching
influence of the air and begin to grow
imaginative
to dream dreams and see apparitions
i mention this peaceful spot with all
possible lawd
for it is in such little retired dutch
valleys found here and there and bosomed
in the great state of new york
that population manners and customs
remain
fixed while the great torrent of
migration and improvement
which is making such incessant changes
and other parts of this restless country
sweeps by them unobserved they are like
those little nooks of still water
which border a rapid stream where we may
see the straw and bubble riding quietly
at anchor
or slowly revolving in their mimic
harbor undisturbed by the rush of the
passing current
though many years have elapsed since i
trod the drowsy shades of sleepy hollow
yet i question whether i should not
still find the same trees
and the same families vegetating in its
sheltered bosom
in this buy place of nature their abode
in a remote period of american history
that is to say some 30 years since a
worthy white
of the name of ichabod crane who
sojourned
or as he expressed it tarried in sleepy
hollow
for the purpose of instructing the
children of the vicinity
he was a native of connecticut a state
which supplies the union with pioneers
for the mind as well as for the forest
and sends forth yearly its legions of
frontier woodmen
and country schoolmasters the cognament
of crane was not inapplicable to his
person
he was tall but exceedingly lank with
narrow
shoulders long arms and legs hands that
dangled a mile out of his sleeves
feet that might have served for shovels
and his whole frame most loosely hung
together
his head was small and flat at top with
huge ears
large green glassy eyes and a long
sniped nose
so that it looked like a weather [ __ ]
perched upon his spindle neck
to tell which way the wind blew to see
him striding along the profile of a hill
on a windy day with his clothes bagging
and fluttering about him
one might have mistaken him for the
genius of famine descending upon the
earth
or some scarecrow eloped from a
cornfield
his schoolhouse was a low building of
one large room
rudely constructed of logs the windows
partly glazed and partly patched with
leaves of old copy books
it was most ingeniously secured at
vacant hours
by a with twisted in the handle of the
door and stakes set against the window
shutters
so that though a thief might get in with
perfect ease
he would find some embarrassment in
getting out an idea most probably
borrowed by the architect
jost van houten from the mystery of an
eel pot
the schoolhouse stood in a rather lonely
but pleasant situation
just at the foot of a woody hill with a
brook running close by
and a formidable birch tree growing at
one end of it
from hence the low murmur of his
people's voices conning over their
lessons
might be heard in a drowsy summer's day
like the hum of a beehive
interrupted now and then by the
authoritative voice of the master
in the tone of menace or command or per
adventure
by the appalling sound of the birch as
he urged some tardy loiterer along the
flowery path of knowledge
truth to say he was a conscientious man
ever bore in mind the golden maxim spare
the rod and spoil the child
ichabod crane's scholars certainly were
not spoiled
i would not have it imagined however
that he was one of those cruel
potentates of the school
who joy and the smart of their subjects
on the contrary he administered justice
with discrimination rather than severity
taking the burden off the backs of the
weak and laying it on those of the
strong
your mere puny stripling that winced at
the least flourish of the rod
was passed by with indulgence but the
claims of justice were satisfied by
inflicting a double portion
on some little tough wrong-headed
broad-skirted dutch urchin
who sulked and swelled and grew dogged
and sullen beneath the birch
all this he called doing his duty by
their parents
and he never inflicted a chastisement
without following it by the assurance
so consolatory to the smarting urchin
that he would remember it and thank him
for it the longest day he had to live
when school hours were over he was even
the companion and playmate of the larger
boys
and on holiday afternoons would convoy
some of the smaller ones home
who happened to have pretty sisters or
good housewives from others
noted for the comforts of the cupboard
indeed it behooved him to keep on good
terms with his pupils
the revenue arising from his school was
small and would have been scarcely
sufficient to furnish him with daily
bread
for he was a huge feeder and though lank
had the dilating powers of an anaconda
but to help out his maintenance he was
according to country custom in those
parts
boarded and lodged at the houses of the
farmers whose children he instructed
with these he lived successively a week
at a time
thus going the rounds of the
neighborhood with all his worldly
effects
tied up in a cotton handkerchief that
all this might not be too onerous on the
purses of his rustic patrons
who are apt to consider the costs of
schooling a grievous burden
and school masters as mere drones he had
various ways of rendering himself both
useful
and agreeable he assisted the farmers
occasionally
in the lighter labors of their farms
helped to make hay
mended the fences took the horses to
water drove the cows from pasture
and cut wood for the winter fire he laid
aside too
all the dominant dignity and absolute
sway with which he lorded it in his
little empire
the school and became wonderfully gentle
and ingratiating
he found favor in the eyes of the
mothers by petting the children
particularly the youngest and like the
lion bold
which while him so magnanimously the
lamb did hold
he would sit with a child on one knee
and rock a cradle with his foot for
whole hours together
in addition to his other vocations he
was the singing master of the
neighborhood
and picked up many bright shillings by
instructing the young folks in somebody
it was a matter of no little vanity to
him on sundays
to take his station in front of the
church gallery with a band of chosen
singers
where in his own mind he completely
carried away the palm from the parson
certain it is his voice resounded far
above all the rest of the congregation
and there are peculiar quavers still to
be heard in that church
and which may even be heard half a mile
off quite to the opposite side of the
mill pond on a still sunday morning
which are said to be legitimately
descended from the nose of ichabod crane
thus
by diverse little makeshifts in that
ingenious way which is commonly
denominated by hook and by crook
the worthy pedagog got on tolerably
enough and was thought
by all who understood nothing of the
labor of headwork to have a wonderfully
easy life of it
the schoolmaster is generally a man of
some importance
in the female circle of a rural
neighborhood being considered a kind of
idle gentleman-like personage
a vastly superior taste and
accomplishments to the rough country
swains
and indeed inferior in learning only to
the parson
his appearance therefore is apt to
occasion some little stir at the tea
table of a farmhouse
and the addition of a supernumerary dish
of cakes or sweet meats
or per adventure the parade of a silver
teapot
our man of letters therefore was
peculiarly happy
in the smiles of all the country damsels
how he would figure among them in the
churchyard between
services on sundays gathering grapes for
them from the wild vines that overran
the surrounding trees
reciting for their amusement all the
epitaphs on the tombstones
or sauntering with a whole bevy of them
along the banks of the adjacent millpond
while the more bashful country bumpkins
hung sheepishly back
envying his superior elegance and
address
from his half itinerant life also he was
kind of a traveling gazette carrying the
whole budget of local gossip from house
to house
so that his appearance was always
greeted with satisfaction
he was moreover esteemed by the women as
a man of great irritation
for he had read several books quite
through and was a perfect master of
cotton mather's history of new england
witchcraft
in which by the way he most firmly and
potently believed
he was in fact an odd mixture of small
shrewdness and simple credulity
his appetite for the marvelous and his
powers of digesting it
were equally extraordinary and both had
been increased by his residence in this
spellbound region
no tail was too gross or monstrous for
his capacious swallow
it was often his delight after his
school was dismissed in the afternoon
to stretch himself on the rich bed of
clover bordering the little brook that
whimpered by his schoolhouse
and there khan over old mather's dire
full tails
until the gathering dusk of evening made
the printed page a mere mist before his
eyes
then as he wended his way by swamp and
stream and awful woodland
to the farmhouse where he happened to be
quartered every sound of nature
at that witching hour fluttered his
excited imagination
the moan of the whippoorwill from the
hillside the boating cry of the tree
toad
that harbinger of storm the dreary
hooting of a screech owl
or the sudden rustling in the thicket of
birds frightened from their roost
the fireflies too which sparkled most
vividly in the darkest places
now and then startled him as one of
uncommon brightness would stream across
his path and if by chance a huge
blockhead of a beetle
came winging his blundering flight
against him the poor varlet was ready to
give up the ghost
with the idea that he was struck with a
witch's token
his only resource on such occasions
either to drown thought or drive away
evil spirits
was to sing psalm tunes and the good
people of sleepy hollow
as they sat by their doors of an evening
were often filled with awe
adhering his nasal melody in linked
sweetness long drawn out
floating from the distant hill or along
the dusky road
another of his sources of fearful
pleasure was to pass
long winter evenings with the old dutch
wives as they sat
spinning by the fire with a row of
apples roasting and spluttering along
the hearth
and listened to their marvelous tales of
ghosts and goblins
and haunted fields and haunted brooks
and haunted bridges and haunted houses
and particularly of the headless
horseman or galloping hessian of the
hollow
as they sometimes called him he would
delight them equally by his anecdotes of
witchcraft
and of the dire full omens and
portentous sights and sounds in the air
which prevailed in the earlier times of
connecticut and would frighten them
woefully with speculations upon comets
and shooting stars
and with the alarming fact that the
world did absolutely turn round
and that they were half the time topsy
turvy
but if there was a pleasure in all this
while snugly cuddling in the chimney
corner of a chamber that was all of a
ruddy glow from the crackling wood fire
and where of course no specter dared to
show its face
it was dearly purchased by the terrors
of his subsequent walk homewards
what fearful shapes and shadows beset
his path
amidst the dim and ghastly glare of a
snowy night
with what wistful look did he eye every
trembling ray of light streaming across
the waist fields from some distant
window
how often was he appalled by some shrub
covered with snow
which like a sheeted specter beset his
very path
how often did he shrink with curdling
awe at the sound of his own steps on the
frosty crust beneath his feet
and dread to look over his shoulder lest
he should behold some
uncouth being tramping close behind him
and how often was he thrown into
complete dismay by some rushing blast
howling among the trees in the idea that
it was the galloping hessian
on one of his nightly scourings all
these however
were mere terrors of the night phantoms
of the mind that walk in darkness
and though he had seen many specters in
his time and been more than once beset
by satan
in diverse shapes in his lonely
perambulations
yet daylight put an end to all these
evils and he would have passed a
pleasant life of it
in despite of the devil and all his
works if
his path had not been crossed by a being
that causes more perplexity to mortal
man
than ghosts goblins and the whole race
of witches put together and that was
a woman among the musical disciples who
assembled one evening and each week
to receive his instructions in somebody
was katrina van tassel
the daughter and only child of a
substantial dutch farmer
she was a blooming lass of fresh 18
plump as a partridge
ripe and melting and rosy cheeked as one
of her father's peaches
and universally famed not merely for her
beauty
but her vast expectations she was with
all
a little of a coquette as might be
perceived even in her dress
which was a mixture of ancient and
modern fashions as most
suited to set off her charms she wore
the ornaments of pure yellow gold
which her great-great-grandmother had
brought over from sardom
the tempting stomacher of the olden time
and with all
a provokingly short petticoat to display
the prettiest foot and
ankle in the country around ichabod
crane had a soft and foolish heart
towards the sex
and it is not to be wondered that so
tempting a morsel soon found favor in
his eyes
more especially after he had visited her
in her paternal mansion
old balta's fan tassel was a perfect
picture of a thriving contented
liberal-hearted farmer he seldom it is
true
sent either his eyes or his thoughts
beyond the boundaries of his own farm
but within those everything was snug
happy and well conditioned
he was satisfied with his wealth but not
proud of it
and peaked himself upon the hearty
abundance rather than the style in which
he lived
his stronghold was situated on the banks
of the hudson
in one of those green sheltered fertile
nooks in which the dutch farmers are so
fond of nestling
a great elm tree spread its broad
branches over it
at the foot of which bubbled up a spring
of the softest and sweetest
water in a little well formed of a
barrel and then stole sparkling away
through the grass
to a neighboring brook that babbled
along among alders and dwarf willows
hard by the farmhouse was a vast barn
that might have served for a church
every window and crevice of which seemed
bursting forth with the treasures of the
farm
the flail was busily resounding within
it from morning to night
swallows and martins skimmed twittering
about the eaves
and rows of pigeons some with one eye
turned up
as if watching the weather some with
their heads under their wings or buried
in their bosoms
and others swelling and cooing and
bowing about their dames
were enjoying the sunshine on the roof
sleek unwieldy porkers were grunting in
the repose and abundance of their pens
from whence sallied forth now and then
troops of suckling pigs
as if to snuff the air a stately
squadron of snowy geese were riding in
an adjoining pond
convoying whole fleets of ducks
regiments of turkeys were gobbling
through the farm yard
and guinea fowls fretting about it like
ill-tempered housewives
with their peevish discontented cry
before the barn door strutted the
gallant [ __ ] that pattern of a husband
a warrior and a fine gentleman clapping
his burnished wings and crowing in the
pride and gladness of his heart
sometimes tearing up the earth with his
feet and then generously calling his
ever-hungry family of wives and children
to enjoy the rich morsel which he had
discovered
the pedagogue's mouth watered as he
looked upon the sumptuous promise of
luxurious winter fair
in his devouring mind's eye he pictured
to himself
every roasting pig running about with a
pudding in his belly
and an apple in his mouth the pigeons
were snuggly put to bed in a comfortable
pie
and tucked in with a coverlet of crust
the geese were swimming in their own
gravy
and the ducks pairing cozily in dishes
like snug married couples
with a decent competency of onion sauce
in the porkers he saw carved out the
future sleek side of bacon
and juicy relishing ham not a turkey
but he beheld daintily trussed up with
its gizzard under its wing
and per adventure a necklace of savory
sausages
and even bright chanticleer himself lay
sprawling on his back in a side dish
with uplifted claws as if craving that
quarter which his chivalrous spirit
disdained to ask while living
as the enraptured ichabod fancied all
this and as he rolled his great green
eyes over the fat
meadowlands the rich fields of wheat a
rye of buckwheat and indian corn
and the orchards burdened with ruddy
fruit which surrounded the warm tenement
of van tassel
his heart yearned after the damsel who
was to inherit these domains
and his imagination expanded with the
idea how they might be readily turned
into cash
and the money invested in immense tracts
of wild land
and shingle palaces in the wilderness
nay his busy fancy already realized his
hopes
and presented to him the blooming
katrina with a whole family of children
mounted on the top of a wagon loaded
with household trumpery
with pots and kettles dangling beneath
and he beheld himself bestriding a
pacing mare with a colt at her heels
setting out for kentucky tennessee or
the lord knows where
when he entered the house the conquest
of his heart was complete
it was one of those spacious farmhouses
with high ridged but lowly sloping roofs
built in the style handed down from the
first dutch settlers
the low projecting eaves forming a
piazza along the front
capable of being closed up in bad
weather
under this were hung flails harness
various utensils of husbandry
and nets for fishing in the neighboring
river
benches were built along the sides for
summer use
and a great spinning wheel at one end
and a churn at the other
showed the various uses to which this
important porch might be devoted
from this piazza the wondering ichabod
entered the hall
which formed the center of the mansion
and the place of usual residents
here rose of resplendent pewter ranged
along a long dresser
dazzled his eyes in one corner stood a
huge bag of wool
ready to be spun in another a quantity
of lindsey woolsey just from the loom
ears of indian corn and strings of dried
apples and peaches
hung in gay festoons along the walls
mingled with the god of red peppers
and adora left a jar gave him a peep
into the best parlor where the
claw-footed chairs and dark mahogany
tables shone like mirrors
and irons with their accompanying shovel
and tongs
glistened from their covert of asparagus
tops
mock oranges and conch shells decorated
the mantelpiece
strings of various colored bird's eggs
were suspended above it
a great ostrich egg was hung from the
center of the room
and a corner cupboard knowingly left
open displayed immense treasures of
old silver and well-mended china
from the moment ichabod laid his eyes
upon these regions of delight
the peace of his mind was at an end and
his only study was how to gain the
affections of the peerless daughter of
van tassel
in this enterprise however he had more
real difficulties than generally fell to
the lot of a knight errant of yore
who seldom had anything but giants
enchanters
fiery dragons and such like easily
conquered adversaries
to contend with and had to make his way
merely through gates of iron and brass
and walls of adamant to the castle keep
where the lady of his heart was confined
all which he achieved as easily as a man
would carve his way to the center of a
christmas pie
and then the lady gave him her hand as a
matter of course
ichabod on the contrary had to win his
way to the heart of a country coquette
beset with a labyrinth of whims and
caprices
which were forever presenting new
difficulties and impediments
and he had to encounter a host of
fearful adversaries of real flesh and
blood
the numerous rustic admirers who beset
every portal to her heart
keeping a watchful and angry eye upon
each other but ready to
fly out in the common cause against any
new competitor
among these the most formidable was a
burly roaring roystering blade
of the name of abraham or according to
the dutch abbreviation
brahm van brunt the hero of the country
round
which rang with his feats of strength
and hearty hood
he was broad-shouldered and
double-jointed with short curly black
hair
and a bluff but not unpleasant
countenance having a mingled air of
fun and arrogance from his herculean
frame and great powers of limb
he had received the nickname of brom
bones
by which he was universally known he was
famed for great knowledge and skill and
horsemanship
being as dexterous on horseback as a
tartar
he was foremost at all races and
cockfights and with the ascendancy which
bodily strength always acquires in
rustic
life was the umpire in all disputes
setting his hat on one side and giving
his decisions with an air and tone that
admitted of no gainsay or appeal
he was always ready for either a fight
or a frolic
but had more mischief than ill will in
his composition
and with all his overbearing roughness
there was a strong dash of waggish good
humor at bottom
he had three or four boon companions who
regarded him as their model
and at the head of whom he scoured the
country attending every scene of feud or
merriment for miles round
in cold weather he was distinguished by
a fur cap
surmounted with a flaunting fox's tail
and when the folks at a country
gathering described this well-known
crest at a distance
whisking about among a squad of hard
riders they always stood by for a squall
sometimes his crew would be heard
dashing along past the farmhouses at
midnight
with whoop and hello like a troop of don
cossex
and the old dames startled out of their
sleep would listen for a moment till the
hurry scurry had clattered by
and then exclaim aye there goes brom
bones and his gang
the neighbors looked upon him with a
mixture of awe admiration
and goodwill and when any madcap prank
or rustic brawl
occurred in the vicinity always shook
their heads
and warranted brom bones was at the
bottom of it
this rantapol hero had for some time
singled out the blooming katrina for the
object of his uncouth gallantries
and though his amorous toyings were
something like the gentle caresses and
endearments of a bear
yet it was whispered that she did not
altogether discourage his hopes
certain it is his advances were signals
for rival candidates to retire
who felt no inclination to cross a lion
in his amores
in so much that when his horse was seen
tied to van tassel's paling on a sunday
night
a sure sign that his master was courting
or as it is termed sparking
within all other suitors passed by in
despair
and carried the war into other quarters
such was the formidable rival with whom
ichabod crane had to contend
and considering all things a stouter man
than he would have shrunk from the
competition
and a wiser man would have despaired he
had however
a happy mixture of pliability and
perseverance in his nature
he was in form and spirit like a supple
jack
yielding but tough though he bent he
never broke
and though he bowed beneath the
slightest pressure yet the moment it was
away
jerk he was as erect and carried his
head as high as ever
to have taken the field openly against
his rival
would have been madness for he was not a
man to be thwarted in his amores
any more than that stormy lover achilles
ichabod therefore
made his advances in a quiet and gently
insinuating manner
under cover of his character of singing
master he made frequent visits at the
farmhouse
not that he had anything to apprehend
from the meddlesome interference of
parents
which is so often a stumbling block in
the path of lovers
balt van tassel was an easy indulgent
soul
he loved his daughter better even than
his pipe
and like a reasonable man and an
excellent father let her have her way
in everything his notable little wife
too had enough to do to attend to her
housekeeping
and manage her poultry for as she sagely
observed
ducks and geese are foolish things and
must be looked after
but girls can take care of themselves
thus while the busy dame bustled about
the house or plied her spinning wheel
at one end of the piazza honest balt
would sit
smoking his evening pipe at the other
watching the achievements of a little
wooden warrior
who armed with a sword in each hand was
most valiantly fighting the wind on the
pinnacle of the barn
in the meantime ichabod would carry on
his suit with the daughter by the side
of the spring under the great elm
or sauntering along in the twilight that
hour so favorable to the lover's
eloquence
i profess not to know how women's hearts
are wooed and won
to me they have always been matters of
riddle and admiration
some seem to have but one vulnerable
point or door of access
while others have a thousand avenues and
may be captured in a thousand different
ways
it is a great triumph of skill to gain
the former
but is still greater proof of
generalship to maintain possession of
the latter
for man must battle for his fortress at
every door and window
he who wins a thousand common hearts is
therefore entitled to some renown
but he who keeps undisputed sway over
the heart of a coquette
is indeed a hero certain it is this was
not the case with the redoubtable brom
bones and from the moment ichabod crane
made his advances
the interests of the former evidently
declined
his horse was no longer seen tied to the
palings on sunday nights
and a deadly feud gradually arose
between him
and the preceptor of sleepy hollow brahm
who had a degree of rough chivalry in
his nature would feign have carried
matters to open warfare and have settled
their pretensions to the lady according
to the mode of those most concise
and simple reasoners the knight's errant
of yore by
single combat but ichabod was too
conscious of the superior might of his
adversary to enter the lists against him
he had overheard a boast of bones that
he would double the schoolmaster up
and lay him on a shelf of his own
schoolhouse and he was too wary to give
him an opportunity
there was something extremely provoking
in this obstinately pacific system
it left brahm no alternative but to draw
upon the funds of rustic waggery in his
disposition
and to play off boorish practical jokes
upon his rival
ichabod became the object of whimsical
persecution to bones
and his gang of rough riders they
harried his hitherto peaceful domains
smoked out his singing school by
stopping up the chimney
broke into the schoolhouse at night in
spite of its formidable fastenings of
wythe than window stakes
and turned everything topsy-turvy so
that the poor schoolmaster began to
think all the witches in the country
held their meetings there
but what was still more annoying brahm
took all opportunities of turning him
into ridicule
in presence of his mistress and had a
scoundrel dog
whom he taught to wine in the most
ludicrous manner and introduced as a
rival of ichabods
to instruct her in somebody in this way
matters went on for some time
without producing any material effect on
the relative situations of the
contending powers
on a fine autumnal afternoon ichabod in
pensive mood
sat enthroned on the lofty stool from
whence he usually watched all the
concerns of his little
literary realm in his hand he swayed a
feral
that scepter of despotic power the birch
of justice reposed on three nails behind
the throne
a constant terror to evildoers while on
the desk before him
might be seen sundry contraband articles
and prohibited weapons
detected upon the persons of idol
urchins
such as half-munched apples pop guns
whirly gigs
fly cages and whole legions of rampant
little paper gamecocks
apparently there had been some appalling
act of justice recently inflicted
for his scholars were all busily intent
upon their books
or slyly whispering behind them with one
eye kept upon the master and a kind of
buzzing stillness
reigned throughout the school room it
was suddenly interrupted by the
appearance of a negro and tow cloth
jacket and trousers
a round crown fragment of a hat like the
cap of mercury
and mounted on the back of a ragged wild
half-broken cult
which he managed with a rope by way of
halter
he came clattering up to the school door
with an invitation to ichabod to attend
a merrymaking
or a quilting frolic to be held that
evening at mine here van tassels
and having delivered his message with
that air of importance
and effort at fine language which in
negro is apt to display
on petty embassies of the kind he dashed
over the brook
and was seen scampering away up the
hollow full of the importance and hurry
of his mission
all was now bustle and hubbub in the
late quiet school room
the scholars were hurried through their
lessons without stopping at trifles
those who were nimble skipped over half
with impunity
and those who were tardy had a smart
application now and then
in the rear to quicken their speed or
help them over a tall word
books were flung aside without being put
away on the shelves
ink stands were overturned benches
thrown down
and the whole school was turned loose an
hour before the usual time
bursting forth like a legion of young
imps yelping and racketing about the
green
and joy at their early emancipation the
gal and ichabod now spent at least an
extra half hour at his toilet
brushing and furbishing up his best and
indeed only suit of rusty black
and arranging his locks by a bit of
broken looking glass that hung up in the
schoolhouse
that he might make an appearance before
his mistress and the true style of a
cavalier
he borrowed a horse from the farmer with
whom he was dumb assiliated
a choleric old dutchman of the name of
hans van ripper
and thus gallantly mounted issued forth
like a night errant and quest of
adventures
but it is meat i should in the true
spirit of romantic story
give some account of the looks and
equipments of my hero
and his steed the animal he bestrode
was a broken down plow horse that had
outlived almost everything but its
viciousness
he was gaunt and shagged with a u-neck
and a head like a hammer
his rusty mane and tail were tangled and
nodded with burrs
one eye had lost its pupil and was
glaring and spectral
but the other had the gleam of a genuine
devil in it
still he must have had fire and metal in
his day
if we may judge from the name he bore of
gunpowder
he had in fact been a favorite steed of
his masters
the choleric van ripper who was a
furious rider
and had infused very probably some of
his own spirit into the animal
four old and broken down as he looked
there was more of the lurking devil in
him than in any young philly in the
country
ichabod was a suitable figure for such a
steed
he rode with short stirrups which
brought his knees nearly up to the
pommel of the saddle
his sharp elbows stuck out like
grasshoppers
he carried his whip perpendicularly in
his hand like a scepter
and as his horse jogged on the motion of
his arms was not unlike the flapping of
a pair of wings
a small wool hat rested on the top of
his nose
for so his scanty strip of forehead
might be called
and the skirts of his black coat
fluttered out almost to the horse's tail
such was the appearance of ichabod and
his steed as they shambled out of the
gate of hans van ripper
and it was all together such an
apparition as a seldom to be met with in
broad daylight
it was as i have said a fine autumnal
day
the sky was clear and serene and nature
were that rich and golden livery which
we always associate with the idea of
abundance
the forests had put on their sober brown
and yellow
while some trees of the tenderer kind
had been nipped by the frosts
into brilliant dyes of orange purple and
scarlet
streaming files of wild ducks begin to
make their appearance high in the air
the bark of the squirrel might be heard
from the groves of beech and hickory
nuts
and the pensive whistle of the quail at
intervals from the neighboring stubble
field
the small birds were taking their
farewell banquets
in the fullness of their revelry they
fluttered chirping and frolicking from
bush to bush
and treeed a tree capricious from the
very profusion and variety around them
there was the honest [ __ ] robin the
favorite game of stripling sportsmen
with its loud queerless note and the
twittering blackbirds flying in sable
clouds
and the golden winged woodpecker with
his crimson crest
his broad black gorget and splendid
plumage
and the cedar bird with its red tipped
wings and yellow tipped tail
and its little montero cap of feathers
and the blue jay
that noisy coxcomb in his gay light blue
coat and white underclothes
screaming and chattering nodding and
bobbing and bowing
and pretending to be on good terms with
every songster of the grove
as ichabod jogged slowly on his way his
eye
ever opened to every symptom of culinary
abundance
ranged with delight over the treasures
of jolly autumn
on all sides he beheld vast stores of
apples
some hanging at oppressive opulence on
the trees
some gathered into baskets and barrels
for the market
others heaped up in rich piles for the
cider press
farther on he beheld great fields of
indian corn
with its golden ears peeping from their
leafy coverts
and holding out the promise of cakes and
hasty pudding
and the yellow pumpkins lying beneath
them turning up their fair round bellies
to the sun
and giving ample prospects of the most
luxurious of pies
and anon he passed the fragrant
buckwheat fields breathing the odor of
the beehive
and as he beheld them soft anticipation
stole over his mind
of dainty slapjacks well buttered and
garnished with honey or treacle
by the delicate little dimpled hand of
katrina van tassel
thus feeding his mind with many sweet
thoughts and sugared suppositions
he journeyed along the sides of a range
of hills which look out upon some of the
goodliest scenes of the mighty hudson
the sun gradually wheeled his broad disk
down in the west
the wide bosom of the tappan zee lay
motionless and glassy
accepting that here and there a gentle
undulation waved and prolonged the blue
shadow of the distant mountain
a few amber clouds floated in the sky
without a breath of air to move them
the horizon was a fine golden tint
changing gradually
into a pure apple green and from that
into the deep blue of the mid heaven
a slanting ray lingered on the woody
crests of the precipices that overhung
some parts of the river
giving greater depth to the dark grey
and purple of their rocky sides
a sloop was loitering in the distance
dropping slowly down with the tide
her sail hanging uselessly against the
mast
and as the reflection of the sky gleamed
along the still water
it seemed as if the vessel was suspended
in the air it was toward evening that
ichabod arrived at the castle of the
here van tassel
which he found thronged with the pride
and flower of the adjacent country
old farmers a spare leather-faced race
in homespun coats and breeches
blue stockings huge shoes and
magnificent pewter buckles
their brisk withered little dames in
close crimped caps
long-wasted short gowns home spun
petticoats
with scissors and pin cushions and gay
calico pockets hanging on the outside
buxom lasses almost as antiquated as
their mothers
accepting wear a straw hat a fine ribbon
or perhaps a white frock
gave symptoms of city innovation
the suns in short square skirted coats
with rows of stupendous brass buttons
and their hair generally cued in the
fashion of the times
especially if they could procure an eel
skin for the purpose
it being esteemed throughout the country
as a potent nourisher and strengthener
of the hair
brom bones however was the hero of the
scene
having come to the gathering on his
favorite steed daredevil
a creature like himself full of metal
and mischief
and which no one but himself could
manage he was in fact
noted for preferring vicious animals
given to all kinds of tricks which kept
the rider in constant risk of his neck
for he held a tractable well-broken
horse as unworthy
of a lad of spirit feign would i pause
to dwell upon the world of charms that
burst upon the enraptured gaze of my
hero
as he entered the state parlor of van
tassel's mansion
not those of the bevy of buxom lasses
with their luxurious display of red and
white
but the ample charms of a genuine dutch
country tea table
in the sumptuous time of autumn such
heaped up platters of cakes of various
and almost
indescribable kinds known only to
experience dutch housewives
there was the dowdy doughnut the tender
olichoic
and the crisp and crumbling crawler
sweet cakes and shortcakes
ginger cakes and honey cakes and the
whole family of cakes
and then there were apple pies and peach
pies and pumpkin pies
besides slices of ham and smoked beef
and moreover delectable dishes of
preserved plums and peaches and pears
and quinces
not to mention broiled shad and roasted
chickens
together with bowls of milk and cream
all mingled higgledy piggledy
pretty much as i have enumerated them
with a motherly teapot sending up its
clouds of vapor
from the midst heaven blessed the mark i
want breath
and time to discuss this banquet as it
deserves and am too eager to get on with
my story
happily ichabod crane was not in so
great a hurry as his historian
but did ample justice to every dainty
he was a kind and thankful creature
whose heart dilated in proportion
as his skin was filled with good cheer
and whose spirits rose with eating
as some mens do with drink he could not
help too
rolling his large eyes around him as he
ate and chuckling with the possibility
that he might one day be lord of all
this scene
of almost unimaginable luxury and
splendor
then he thought how soon he'd turn his
back upon the old school house
snap his fingers in the face of hans van
ripper and every other niggerly patron
and kick any itinerant pedagogue out of
doors that should dare to call him
comrade
old baltus van tassel moved about among
his guests with a face
dilated with content and good humor
round and jolly as the harvest moon
his hospitable attentions were brief but
expressive
being confined to a shake of the hand a
slap on the shoulder
a loud laugh and a pressing invitation
to fall too and help themselves
and now the sound of the music from the
common room or hall
summoned to the dance the musician was
an old gray-headed negro
who had been the itinerant orchestra of
the neighborhood for more than half a
century
his instrument was as old and battered
as himself
the greater part of the time he scraped
on two or three strings
accompanying every movement of the bow
with a motion of the head
bowing almost to the ground and stamping
with his foot whenever a fresh couple
were to start
ichabod prided himself upon his dancing
as much as upon his vocal powers
not a limb not a fiber about him was
idle
and to have seen his loosely hung frame
in full motion
and clattering about the room you would
have thought saint vitus himself
that blessed patron of the dance was
figuring before you in person
he was the admiration of all the negroes
who having gathered of all ages and
sizes
from the farm in the neighborhood stood
forming a pyramid of shining black faces
at every door and window
gazing with delight at the scene rolling
their white eyeballs
and showing grinning rows of ivory from
ear to ear
how could the flogger of urchins be
otherwise than animated and joyous
the lady of his heart was his partner in
the dance and smiling graciously in
reply to all his amorous oglings
while brom bones sorely smitten with
love and jealousy
sat brooding by himself in one corner
when the dance was at an end ichabod was
attracted to a knot of the sager folks
who with old van tassel sat smoking at
one end of the piazza
gossiping over former times and drawing
out long stories about the war
this neighborhood at the time of which i
am speaking
was one of those highly favored places
which abound with chronical and great
men
the british and american line had run
near it during the war
it had therefore been the scene of
marauding and infested with refugees
cowboys and all kinds of border chivalry
just sufficient time had a lapse to
enable each storyteller to dress up his
tale with a little becoming fiction
and in the indistinctness of his
recollection to make himself the hero
of every exploit there was the story of
daffy
martling a large blue bearded dutchman
who had nearly taken a british frigate
with an old iron nine pounder from a mud
breastwork
only that his gun burst at the sixth
discharge
and there was an old gentleman who shall
be nameless being too rich a mine here
to be lightly mentioned
who in the battle of white plains being
an excellent master of defense
parried a musket ball with a small sword
in so much that he absolutely felt it
whiz around the blade
and glance off at the hilt in proof of
which he was ready at any time
to show the sword with the hilt a little
bent
there were several more that had been
equally great in the field
not one of whom but was persuaded that
he had a considerable hand in bringing
the war to a happy termination
but all these were nothing to the tales
of ghosts and apparitions that succeeded
the neighborhood is rich and legendary
treasures of the kind
local tales and superstitions thrive
best in these sheltered long-settled
retreats
but are trampled underfoot by the
shifting throng that forms the
population of most of our country places
besides there is no encouragement for
ghosts in most of our villages
for they have scarcely had time to
finish their first nap
and turn themselves in their graves
before their surviving friends have
traveled away from the neighborhood
so that when they turn out at night to
walk their rounds they have no
acquaintance left to call upon
this is perhaps the reason why we so
seldom hear of ghosts
except in our long-established dutch
communities
the immediate cause however of the
prevalence of supernatural stories in
these parts
was doubtless owing to the vicinity of
sleepy hollow
there was a contagion in the very air
that blew from that haunted region
it breathed forth an atmosphere of
dreams and fancies
infecting all the land several of the
sleepy hollow people were present at van
tassels
and as usual were doling out their wild
and wonderful legends
many dismal tales were told about
funeral trains
and morning cries and wailings heard and
seen about the great tree
where the unfortunate major andre was
taken and which stood in the
neighborhood
some mention was made also of the woman
in white that haunted the dark glen at
raven rock
and was often heard to shriek on winter
nights before a storm
having perished there in the snow the
chief part of the stories however
turned upon the favorite specter of
sleepy hollow the headless horseman
who had been heard several times of late
patrolling the country
and it was said tethered his horse
nightly among the graves in the
churchyard
the sequestered situation of this church
seems always to have made it a favorite
haunt of troubled spirits
it stands on a knoll surrounded by
locust trees and lofty elms
from among which its decent whitewashed
walls shine modestly forth
like christian purity beaming through
the shades of retirement
a gentle slope descends from it to a
silver sheet of water
bordered by high trees between which
peeps may be caught at the blue hills of
the hudson
to look upon its grass-grown yard where
the sunbeam
seemed to sleep so quietly one would
think that there at least
the dead might rest in peace on one side
of the church extends a wide woody del
along which raves a large brook among
broken rocks and trunks of fallen trees
over a deep black part of the stream not
far from the church
was formerly thrown a wooden bridge the
road that led to it
and the bridge itself were thickly
shaded by overhanging trees
which cast a gloom about it even in the
daytime
but occasioned a fearful darkness at
night
such was one of the favorite haunts of
the headless horseman
and the place where he was most
frequently encountered
the tale was told of old brower a most
heretical disbeliever and ghost
how he met the horsemen returning from
his foray into sleepy hollow
and was obliged to get up behind him how
they galloped over bush and break
over hill and swamp until they reached
the bridge
when the horsemen suddenly turned into a
skeleton
threw old brewer into the brook and
sprang away over the treetops with a
clap of thunder
this story was immediately matched by a
thrace marvelous adventure of brom bones
who made light of the galloping hessian
as an errant jockey
he affirmed that on returning one night
from the neighboring village of singsing
he had been overtaken by this midnight
trooper that he had offered to race with
him for a bowl of punch
and should have won it too for daredevil
beat the goblin horse all hollow
but just as they came to the church
bridge the hessian bolted
and vanished in a flash of fire all
these tales
told in that drowsy undertone with which
men talk in the dark
the countenances of the listeners only
now and then receiving a casual gleam
from the glare of a pipe
sank deep in the mind of ichabod he
repaid them in kind with large extracts
from his invaluable author
cotton mather and added many marvelous
events that had taken place in his
native state of connecticut
and fearful sights which he had seen in
his nightly walks about sleepy hollow
the revel now gradually broke up the old
farmers gathered together their families
and their wagons
and were heard for some time rattling
along the hollow roads and over the
distant hills
some of the damsels mounted on pillions
behind their favorite swains
and their light-hearted laughter
mingling with the clatter of hoofs
echoed along the silent woodlands
sounding fainter and fainter
until they gradually died away and the
late scene of noise and frolic was all
silent and deserted ichabod only
lingered behind
according to the custom of country
lovers to have a tet attempt with the
heiress
fully convinced that he was now on the
high road to success
what passed at this interview i will not
pretend to say
for in fact i do not know something
however
i fear me must have gone wrong for he
certainly sallied forth
after no very great interval with an
heir quite desolate and chap-fallen
oh these women these women could that
girl have been playing off any of her
coquettish tricks
was her encouragement of the poor
pedagogue all amir sham
to secure her conquest of his rival
heaven only knows
not i let it suffice to say
ichabod stole forth with the air of one
who had been sacking a henroost
rather than a fair lady's heart without
looking to the right or left
to notice the scene of rural wealth on
which he had so often gloated
he went straight to the stable and with
several hearty cuffs and kicks roused
his steed most
uncourteously from the comfortable
quarters in which he was soundly
sleeping
dreaming of mountains of corn and oats
and whole valleys of timothy and clover
it was the very witching time of night
that ichabod
heavy-hearted and crestfallen pursued
his travels homewards
along the sides of the lofty hills which
rise above terrytown
and which he had traversed so cheerily
in the afternoon
the hour was as dismal as himself
far below him the tappan zee spread its
dusky and indistinct waste of waters
and here and there the tall mast of a
sloop riding quietly at anchor under the
land
in the dead hush of midnight he could
even hear the barking of the watchdog
from the opposite shore of the hudson
but it was so vague and faint as only to
give an idea of its distance from this
faithful companion of
man now and then too the long drawn
crowing of a [ __ ]
accidentally awakened would sound far
far off
from some farmhouse away among the hills
but it was like a dreaming sound in his
ear
no signs of life occurred near him but
occasionally the melancholy chirp of a
cricket
or perhaps the guttural twang of a
bullfrog from a neighboring marsh
as if sleeping uncomfortably and turning
suddenly in his bed
all the stories of ghosts and goblins
that he had heard in the afternoon
now came crowding upon his recollection
the night grew darker and darker the
stars seemed to sink
deeper in the sky and driving clouds
occasionally hid them from his sight
he had never felt so lonely and dismal
he was moreover approaching the very
place where many of the scenes of the
ghost stories had been laid
in the center of the road stood an
enormous tulip tree
which towered like a giant above all the
other trees of the neighborhood
and formed a kind of landmark its limbs
were gnarled and fantastic
large enough to form trunks for ordinary
trees twisting down almost to the earth
and rising again into the air it was
connected with the tragical story of the
unfortunate andre
who had been taken prisoner hard by and
was universally known by the name of
major andre's tree
the common people regarded it with a
mixture of respect and superstition
partly out of sympathy for the fate of
its ill-starred namesake
and partly from the tales of strange
sights and doleful lamentations
told concerning it azikabod approached
this fearful tree
he began to whistle he thought his
whistle was answered
it was but a blast sweeping sharply
through the dry branches
as he approached a little nearer he
thought he saw something white
hanging in the midst of a tree he paused
and ceased whistling
but on looking more narrowly perceived
that it was a place where the tree had
been scathed by lightning
and the white wood laid bare suddenly he
heard a groan
his teeth chattered and his knees smote
against the saddle
it was but the rubbing of one huge bow
upon another
as they were swayed about by the breeze
he passed the tree in safety
but new perils lay before him
about 200 yards from the tree a small
brook crossed the road
and ran into a marshy and thickly wooded
glen known by the name of wily's swamp
a few rough logs laid side by side
served for a bridge over this stream
on that side of the road where the brook
entered the wood a group of oaks and
chestnuts
matted thick with wild grapevines threw
a cavernous gloom over it to pass this
bridge
was the severest trial it was at this
identical spot that the unfortunate
andre was captured
and under the coverts of those chestnuts
and vines were the sturdy yeoman
concealed who surprised him
this has ever since been considered a
haunted stream
and fearful of the feelings of the
schoolboy who has to pass it alone after
dark
as he approached the stream his heart
began to thump
he summoned up however all his
resolution
gave his horse half a score of kicks in
the ribs
and attempted to dash briskly across the
bridge
but instead of starting forward the
perverse old animal made a lateral
movement
and ran broadside against the fence
ichabod whose fears increased with the
delay
jerked the reins on the other side and
kicked lustily with the contrary foot
it was all in vain his steed started it
is true
but it was only to plunge to the
opposite side of the road into a thicket
of brambles and alder bushes
the schoolmaster now bestowed both whip
and heel upon the starving ribs of old
gunpowder
who dashed forward snuffling and
snorting but came to a stand just by the
bridge
with a suddenness that had nearly sent
his rider sprawling over his head
just at this moment a plashy [ __ ] by
the side of the bridge
caught the sensitive ear of ichabod in
the dark shadow of the grove
on the margin of the brook he beheld
something huge
misshapen and towering it stirred not
but seemed gathered up in the gloom like
some gigantic monster
ready to spring upon the traveler the
hair of the a freighted pedagogue
rose upon his head with terror what was
to be done
to turn and fly was now too late and
besides what chance was there of
escaping ghost or goblin
if such it was which could ride upon the
wings of the wind
summoning up therefore a show of courage
he demanded in stammering accents
who are you he received no reply
he repeated his demand in a still more
agitated voice
still there was no answer once more he
cudgeled the sides of the inflexible
gunpowder and shutting his eyes
broke forth with involuntary fervor into
a psalm tune
just then the shadowy object of alarm
put itself in motion
and with a scramble and abound stood at
once in the middle of the road
though the night was dark and dismal yet
the form of the unknown might now in
some degree be ascertained
he appeared to be a horseman of large
dimensions
and mounted on a black horse a powerful
frame
he made no offer of molestation or
sociability
but kept aloof on one side of the road
jogging along on the blind side of old
gunpowder
who had now got over his fright and
waywardness
ichabod who had no relish for this
strange midnight companion
and before himself of the adventure of
brom bones with the galloping hessian
now quickened his steed in hopes of
leaving him behind
the stranger however quickened his horse
to an equal pace
ichabod pulled up and fell into a walk
thinking to lag behind
the other did the same his heart began
to sink within him
he endeavored to resume his psalm tune
but his parched tongue clothed to the
roof of his mouth
and he could not utter a stave there was
something in the moody and dogged
silence of this pertinacious companion
that was mysterious and appalling it was
soon fearfully accounted for
on mounting a rising ground which
brought the figure of his fellow
traveler in relief against the sky
gigantic in height and muffled in a
cloak
ichabod was horror struck on perceiving
that he
was headless but his horror was still
more increased on observing that the
head
which should have rested on his
shoulders was carried before him
on the pommel of his saddle his terror
rose to desperation he reigned a shower
of kicks and blows upon gunpowder
hoping by a sudden movement to give his
companion the slip
but the spectre started full jump with
him
away then they dashed through thick and
thin stones flying and sparks flashing
at every bound
ichabod's flimsy garments fluttered in
the air as he stretched his long length
body away over his horse's head
in the eagerness of his flight they had
now reached the road which turns off to
sleepy hollow
but gunpowder who seemed possessed with
a demon
instead of keeping up it made an
opposite turn and plunged headlong
downhill to the left
this road leads through a sandy hollow
shaded by trees for about
a quarter of a mile where it crosses the
bridge famous and goblin story
and just beyond swells the green knoll
on which stands the whitewashed church
as yet the panic of the steed had given
his unskillful rider an apparent
advantage in the chase
but just as he had got halfway through
the hollow the girths of the saddle gave
way
and he felt it slipping from under him
he seized it by the pommel
and endeavored to hold it firm but in
vain and had just time to save himself
by clasping old gunpowder around the
neck
when the saddle fell to the earth and he
heard it trampled underfoot by his
pursuer
for a moment the terror of hans van
ripper's wrath passed across his mind
for it was his sunday saddle but this
was no time for petty fears
the goblin was hard on his haunches and
unskillful rider that he was
he had much ado to maintain his seat
sometimes slipping on one side
sometimes on another and sometimes
jolted on the high ridge of his horse's
backbone
with a violence that he verily feared
would cleave him asunder
an opening in the trees now cheered him
with the hopes that the church bridge
was at hand
the wavering reflection of a silver star
in the bosom of the brook
told him that he was not mistaken he saw
the walls of the church dimly glaring
under the trees beyond
he recollected the place where brom
bones as ghostly competitor had
disappeared
if i can but reach that bridge thought
ichabod i am safe
just then he heard the black steed
panting and blowing close behind him
he even fancied that he felt his hot
breath
another convulsive kick in the ribs an
old gunpowder sprang upon the bridge
he thundered over the resounding planks
he gained the opposite side
and now ichabod cast a look behind to
see if his pursuer should vanish
according to rule in a flash of fire in
brimstone
just then he saw the goblin rising in
his stirrups
and in the very act of hurling his head
at him
ichabod endeavored to dodge the horrible
missile but too late
it encountered his cranium with a
tremendous crash
he was tumbled headlong into the dust
and gunpowder the black steed and the
goblin rider
passed by like a whirlwind
the next morning the old horse was found
without his saddle
and with the bridle under his feet
soberly cropping the grass at his
master's gate
ichabod did not make his appearance at
breakfast
dinner hour came but no ichabod the boys
assembled at the schoolhouse
and strolled idly about the banks of the
brook but no schoolmaster
hans van ripper now began to feel some
uneasiness about the fate of poor
ichabod
and his saddle an inquiry was set on
foot
and after diligent investigation they
came upon his traces
in one part of the road leading to the
church was found the saddle
trampled in the dirt the tracks of
horses hoofs
deeply dented in the road and evidently
at furious speed
were traced to the bridge beyond which
on the bank of a broad part of the brook
where the water ran deep in black was
found the hat
of the unfortunate ichabod and close
beside it
a shattered pumpkin the brook was
searched
but the body of the schoolmaster was not
to be discovered
hans van ripper as executor of his
estate
examined the bundle which contained all
his worldly effects
they consisted of two shirts and a half
two stalks for the neck
a pair or two of worsted stockings an
old pair of corduroy small clothes
a rusty razor a book of psalm tunes full
of dog's ears
and a broken pitch pipe as to the books
and furniture of the schoolhouse
they belong to the community accepting
cotton mathers history of witchcraft
a new england almanac and a book of
dreams and fortune telling
in which last was a sheet of fool's cap
much scribbled and blotted in several
fruitless attempts to make a copy of
verses in honor of the heiress of van
tassel
these magic books and poetic scrawl were
forthwith consigned to the flames by
hans van ripper
who from that time forward determined to
send his children no more to school
observing that he never knew any good to
come of this same reading and writing
whatever money the schoolmaster
possessed and he had received his
quarter's pay but a day or two before
he must have had about his person at the
time of his disappearance
the mysterious event caused much
speculation at the church on the
following sunday
knots of gazers and gossips were
collected in the churchyard
at the bridge and at the spot where the
hat and pumpkin had been found
the stories of brewer of bones and a
whole budget of others were called to
mind
and when they had diligently considered
them all and compared them with the
symptoms of the present case
they shook their heads and came to the
conclusion that ichabod had been carried
off by the galloping hessian
as he was a bachelor and in nobody's
debt nobody troubled his head any more
about him
the school was removed to a different
quarter of the hollow
and another pedagogue reigned in his
stead
it is true an old farmer who had been
down to new york on a visit several
years after
and from whom this account of the
ghostly adventure was received
brought home the intelligence that
ichabod crane was still alive
that he had left the neighborhood partly
through fear of the goblin and hans van
ripper
and partly in mortification at having
been suddenly dismissed by the heiress
that he had changed his quarters to a
distant part of the country
had kept school and studied law at the
same time
had been admitted to the bar turned
politician
electioneered written for the newspapers
and finally had been made a justice of
the 10-pound court
brom bones too who shortly after his
rival's disappearance
conducted the blooming katrina in
triumph to the altar
was observed to look exceedingly knowing
whenever the story of ichabod was
related
and always burst into a hearty laugh at
the mention of the pumpkin
which led some to suspect that he knew
more about the matter than he chose to
tell
the old country wives however who are
the best judges of these matters
maintained to this day that ichabod was
spirited away
by supernatural means and it is a
favorite story often told about the
neighborhood around the winter evening
fire
the bridge became more than ever an
object of superstitious awe
and that may be the reason why the road
has been altered of late years
so as to approach the church by the
border of the millpond
the schoolhouse being deserted soon fell
to decay
and was reported to be haunted by the
ghost of the unfortunate pedagogue
and the plowboy loitering homeward of a
still summer evening
has often fancied his voice at a
distance chanting a melancholy psalm
tune
among the tranquil solitudes of sleepy
hollow
postscript found in the handwriting of
mr knickerbocker
the preceding tale is given almost in
the precise words in which i heard it
related at a corporation meeting at the
ancient city of manhattan
at which were present many of its sagest
and most illustrious burgers
the narrator was a pleasant shabby
gentlemanly old fellow
in pepper and salt clothes with a sadly
humorous face
and one whom i strongly suspected of
being poor
he made such efforts to be entertaining
when his story was concluded
there was much laughter and approbation
particularly from two or three deputy
aldermen
who had been asleep the greater part of
the time
there was however one tall dry looking
old gentleman
with beetling eyebrows who maintained a
grave and rather severe face throughout
now and then folding his arms inclining
his head
and looking down upon the floor as if
turning a doubt over in his mind
he was one of your weary men who never
laugh but upon good grounds
when they have reason and law on their
side when the mirth of the rest of the
company had subsided
and silence was restored he leaned one
arm on the elbow of his chair
and sticking the other a kimbo demanded
with a slight but exceedingly sage
motion of the head
and contraction of the brow what was the
moral of the story and what it went to
prove
the storyteller who was just putting a
glass of wine to his lips
as a refreshment after his toils paused
for a moment
looked at his enquirer with an air of
infinite deference
and lowering the glass slowly to the
table observed that the story was
intended most logically to prove
that there is no situation in life but
has its advantages and pleasures
provided we will but take a joke as we
find it
that therefore he that runs races with
goblin troopers
is likely to have rough riding of it
ergo for a country schoolmaster to be
refused the hand of a dutch heiress
is a certain step to high performance in
the state
the cautious old gentleman knit his
brows tenfold closer after this
explanation
being sorely puzzled by the rationation
of the syllogism
while me thought the one in pepper and
salt eyed him with something of a
triumphant lear
at length he observed that all this was
very well
but still he thought the story a little
on the extravagant
there were one or two points on which he
had his doubts
faith sir replied the storyteller as to
that
matter i don't believe one half of it
myself
[Music]
dk
[Music]
you